هذا الشادر بدل ما نكون في دورنا وفي
بيوتنا هذا جايبين شادر يسترنا والله الله
ما برضى في الظلم يا عالم هي عرسي على
الطلاق من انا بدي اعيط الحمد
[موسيقى]
لله عاد الزمان علينا
ا اقول قلبي يفرح
اي قد ما بكيت عينينا
ا
[موسيقى]
محمد الغندور 22 سنه خطبت في 28 سته قبل
الحرب بشهر تقريبا شهر وشويه فبعد فتلت سب
بدات احجز
وقربها الحجز اجا مد عرس وانا في الحرب
بقيت مجهز مرتق من النوم مجهزه جهازها كله
وذهبها هذا كله بعوض عليه الله طبعا سبب
النازحه لما وقعت دارهم اجيت اخذتها
واخذتنا سايب وصلنا نجر في الشارع كانت قب
وقع قبليوم قاعدين في المدرسه انا مدرسه
الزيتون لما الوضع بدا يشد في غزه عننا
قلنا يعني حرام شايفين الموت في عينينا
وبضل ب تحاسب لا اطلع واطلعنا زينا زي
هالناس والله ايت و كناش يعني زي ما تقولي
مفكرين وزي زي ما قلت لك تو ربنا في اتفق
ته رحمه اكلت ثلاث ص جايه واحده في اصبعي
واحده في قلبي وواحده في صدري يعني ربنا
من عنده له حكمه ولطفا لما قمت
قمت من العين المركزه وقعدت اربع خمس ايام
في المستشفى وقفت على رجل قلت لابويا انا
خلص بدي اخذ البنت بدي اكمل نص ديني هي
رصينا على حرام واش الحرام الشريه كله
مساعدات بمساعدات وربنا كبير بنساش حدا
السر ربنا من عنده بستره اكثر حاجه
بتمناها في حياتي انه ارجع على دار الاقيه
زي بس لاجل البنت بس لاجل البنت انها تفرح
وخلصنا اما اقوللك في فرحه حتى لو قالتلي
مبسوطه ممكن انبساط البنت ان انا معها اما
في عرس ما فرحها ما فرح ما دخلتش القلب
سواء من عريسها من جوزها ولا من مرتي وزي
ما انتم شايفين انا غرفه نوم غرفه نوم في
خيمه وع السلك مرميين ومافيش حد بيطلع
فينا ولا حد بيجينا ولا حد بيقولنا وين
انتم الحمد لله خلا على الله انت قاعد
بتتكلم القلب قاعد بعيط الدم ب تنزل يعني
كون راجل ماسك حالي يا رب يا حنان بتمنى
من الله تنحل الدنيا والله يدينا الصحه
والعافيه ونكون حالنا نرجع من السفر من شي
ل شي من نص لنص من اثين لاثنين لما بسطتها
وان شاء الله بكره ربنا يقدمنا اعملها فرح
مش فرح وعدتها قلتل نزنا غزه وكان في حلول
وفتحت راس وخلصت الشهداء من الشهداء وكنت
حامل حجيبك في اسبوعه ما كنتش حامل حنعمل
عيد الفرح
[موسيقى]
تاني
ه